wir fangen hallo ich nicht du kannst du
dich ja da sind wir dich mit ski wieder
zusammen vor der kamera
janosch und kam zum zweiten mal heute
gemeinsam vor der kamera dass die reine
wahnsinn oder ja nicht das ist gut
offenbar ihr wisst ja letztes mal haben
wir eine philosophische fragen stellen
ja ist ja unser philosophie meister bei
uns rein im easy german team und er
möchte gerne philosophische fragen
stellen und seine episode weiß
eigentlich dass da eine episode der
meaning of life 729 das ist die
populärste episode auf unserem neuen
easy german kanal war das ist voll schön
über die frage geht ja auch viele leute
locklear
und was ist jetzt eine neue frage die
neue frage haben wir uns gemeinsam
überlegt bzw hat carlina sie rausgesucht
und die lautet wovor haben menschen
angst
dann will ich sagen okay
wovor ich angst habe dass keiner mehr
reden kann ich angst hat auch gottes
ganz schwierig ich weiß gar nicht wovor
ich angst meine ganzen lieben menschen
um mich herum zu verlieren das wäre
eigentlich was vor falschen menschen
darf sagt
ja schon aber nicht immer und im
metaphysischen sinne im metaphysischen
sinne glaube ich findest du fehlt dann
gibt's kein ansprechpartner und wenn man
immer aus seiner eigenen perspektive
alles heraus denkt dann fehlt ein
bisschen die möglichkeit den
perspektivwechsel zu verziehen und
sprache hilft dabei ihre sprache macht
menschen zugänglich
davor habe ich angst ich habe davor
angst es ist nutzlos bin ich glaube
alleine alt zu werden
die frage vielleicht davor irgendwann
allein zu sein finde ich allein sein ist
das schlimmste
da frage ich angst es gibt nirgends ohne
nächsten vorm alleinsein würde ich sagen
und wie gehst du damit um was machst du
damit es dich nicht erdrückt
naja wesentlichen versucht man das ja zu
vermeiden das ist ja wieder mit angst
umgeht und wenn es dann so ist beim
alleinsein finde ich würde einfach wir
haben mussten sie selber auskommen also
das heißt man muss ja den stabilen
charakter haben sozusagen und der wächst
aber auch eben nicht durch allein sein
sondern durch beziehungen
beziehungsfähigkeit dann kann man glaube
ich auch und ich selber am rhein sein
bevor ich angst habe tja aktuell nicht
so viel vor clowns und spinnen
eigentlich habe ich keine angst keine
angst ist gut ja wie schaffen sie das
ich denke das wird schon das ist es gibt
immer probleme und es gibt auch lösungen
mit der zeit wird das ergeben hat
vielleicht dass menschen in meinem namen
umfeld was passiert
denke ich ich glaube ich hab angst vor
der angst und die leute sollten offen
sein und weniger angst haben ich habe
angst dass die leute angst haben
eigentlich wovor ich angst habe zum
beispiel vor arbeitslosigkeit habe ich
angst schwer überleben zu können
vor schweren krankheiten angst habe ich
vor dem tod ich habe angst vor dem tod
wie kommst du kleine wird gut
das ist eine strategie und muss damit
leben
wovor ich angst im metaphysischen sie
vor dem tod zum beispiel
wir kommen nicht klar damit
was ist in der vorstellung was passiert
mit den tod also ich bin nicht religiös
und deshalb denke ich nach dem tod bin
ich einfach tot und ich existiere nicht
mehr
und deshalb habe ich wahrscheinlich auch
angst davor gewarnt einen ja irgendwie
einen und bedrückt einen zu gast war
irgendwie gar nichts mehr machen können
und irgendwie wie gelähmt ist
er persönlich habe ich hier keine angst
aber in die gesellschaft hier hat ja
viel mit dem krieg woanders zu tun
also ich habe angst vor dem politischen
macht missbraucht ich habe zum beispiel
angst vor der kita bewegung dass es zum
beispiel irgendwann mal überhand nimmt
so diese alltags rassistische komponente
und die einheit häufig im alltag
begegnet könnte man als beispiel nehmen
aber da ist jetzt wieder der punkt dass
man da sich selber sagt ich sollte keine
angst haben weil dann haben die menschen
das geschafft was sie schaffen wollen
aktuell habe ich ganz große angst dass
die freiheit die erkämpft wurde von ganz
vielen leuten unternehmer von meiner
mama die sich ihre freiheit in der ddr
kämpft hat kaputt gemacht wird von
leuten die das ausnutzen um zu sagen
dass ausländer scheiße sind nein seid
ihr nicht davor habe ich ganz große
aktuell und du wunder auch also
was momentan so passiert mit den ganzen
wutbürgern leute die meinen sie sein
kann rassisten und trotzdem sich
öffentlich hinstellen und den rechten
arm heben
das macht mir riesengroße sorgen
eigentlich nichts konkretes
im moment habe ich nicht das gefühl ich
vor etwas angst habe das ist ein
dann wünschen wir ihn weiterhin schönes
leben
dankeschön wir sind jung wir sind zurück
aus unserer tour mit der frage wovor
hast du angst es war wunderbar die
menschen am sehr ehrlich und sehr
persönlich und beantwortete und haben
sehr versöhnliche frei wir haben die
leute denn sich überhaupt
also waren die leute breitere zuschauer
ja
irgendwie denkst du mal bei manchen
leuten bei manchen menschen denkst du
die freuen sich sogar das dass sie
antworten können es gab auch welche die
uns abgelehnt haben die gesagt haben
nein das ist mir zu persönlich aber es
gab auch eine frau die gesagt hat dass
sie angst vor dem tod hat und irgendwo
hast du das gefühl ich möchte jetzt
bleiben und ganz lange darüber sprechen
es ist ein sehr sehr wichtiges thema und
alle irgendwie angst vor dem tod oder
nicht ich nicht ich nicht wirklich sehr
ich glaube an den tod nicht weil der tod
ist nicht kein inhalt seiner erfahrung
sofort für jemanden von draußen bitte
ein aber für dich nicht für dich
bedeutet das nichts kann sie trotzdem
davor angst habe ich aber nicht was
der angenehm ist es lebt sich ruhiger
wenn man keine angst hat vor vor dem tod
ihr habt ihr angst vor dem tod habt ihr
noch philosophische fragen schickt sie
uns unbedingt denn wir waren zu hören
ja es geht gerne noch mal raus oder
super gerne wir haben nur eine begrenzte
anzahl von den philosophischen tragen
also wir haben eine unendliche anzahl
wir können mal gucken wie viele ihr habt
schickt uns eure fragen jannis
philosophische frage stunde bei 7 geht
demnächst weiter dafür stehe ich mit
meinem namen danke und tschüss
ich freue mich danke dass ihr
eingeschaltet habt danke dass ihr uns
unterstützt wenn ihr auch lust habt
mitglied bei uns zu werden outtakes
episode zu sehen
dann kommt einfach zu katrin bei uns
unterstützt uns ort und natürlich
abonnieren abonnieren abonnieren mehr
easy german sehen abonnieren
und tschüss